hey everyone had a thought in these
strange times about how to think of each
day you know it's kind of amazing how
our emotions play tricks on us every
little cough or scratch of the sore
throat I can induce concern or panic and
we not about good days bad days but it's
like good moments bad moments sometimes
I think if anyone's like me I feel like
oh yeah I got this on other days I'm
like no don't got this and one of the
things that I've been leaning on is the
infinite mindset that in the infinite
game there is no winning
there is only ahead and behind and so
I've stopped trying to label my days as
good days or bad days or good moments or
bad moments I don't want those things to
become narratives in my head is good or
bad but rather just ahead and behind and
so sometimes I'm having a behind day and
sometimes I'm having a head day but what
I found is that thinking in a head and
behind terms makes me reminds me that
this has an end that this we're that we
will get through this this cut this has
an end date we want this end date to
come quicker and we want this end date
to we want to get there with as little
pain as possible to those around us but
it will end and obviously we won't have
Morehead days in behind days so thought
I would share that thought take care of
yourself take care of others talk to you
soon
[Music]